[Music]
cNN has been so completely over the top
and his coverage of this administration
that those of us who remembered from 20
years ago or in my case used to work
there just stare slacks out of the
screen thinking really can this be
happening last night it went even
farther than normal the network
editorialized in its news Chiron's on in
its Chiron's that the script at the
bottom of the screen twice first in the
Situation Room one Chiron read White
House repeats Trump's false claim that
he's tougher on Russia than Obama that's
an objective claim meanwhile up on
upfront with Erin Burnett a breaking
news Chiron blur this White House : it's
clear Russian meddling had no impact
followed by in parentheses no it's not
Joao Concha writes about the media for
the hill he watches a ton of CNN he's
got a facial twitch and he joins us
tonight Joe
I mean Chiron's and we should just just
to be fair to Wolf Blitzer who I think
does to try pretty hard to keep it
pretty straight but they don't write the
Chiron's but like nobody saw that and
said no that's too far we can't do that
oh no obviously that was a decision in
the control-room tucker and same with
erin burnett right i've been on air and
show a hundred times I like her
personally I respect it professionally I
think she tries to do a good job they
don't have any decision as far as those
Chiron's afterwards they could read the
criticism and say hey guys it's my face
that's on the screen I'm the only one
who's going to get criticism for this so
maybe we should put an end to it but but
as you said the Chiron's like we're
seeing below on our screen right now on
an editorial show on an opinion show
like yours that's fine because it's like
your newspaper right you go to your
editorial page and that that's that's
fine but on news programs that's
something that plays into the narrative
if you're CNN that you are the
opposition party that you're leading the
resistance against the Trump campaign
and not serve as an objective news
organization as it purports to be now
what's a factual Chiron for instance
like today in New York New York
experience record high temperatures in
Central Park that's a fact
Billy Graham dies at age 99 that's
affect when you have breaking news White
House repeats Trump's false claim that
he's tougher on Russia as you said
that's objective and that's an opinion
and John noonan's
he's summed this up best he is the you
know I'll quoted the senior counselor
for military and defense Affairs for
Senator Tom cotton and he said oh by the
way John unit is no relation to Danny
Noonan I just want to make that clear
quote CNN respectfully please tell your
producer not to do this you can't anoint
yourself arbiter in these debates adding
you can get experts to debate the merits
of each administration's policies that's
perfectly fine but this isn't just
putting your finger on the scale it's
sitting on it and I think that sums it
up nicely Chuck that's right and and I
just want me to totally clear the term
Chiron refers to the banner at the
bottom of the screen it's a TV term so I
kind of want confusedly yeah it's
headlining said that's exactly right to
the host is not aware of so are you I
mean have you noticed this all day
these cable news anchors most of them as
far as a network childless lecturing the
rest of us about how we don't love the
children if we don't agree with them on
a very specific political issue guns
have you ever seen the press preach year
than it was today I remember on the gay
marriage rulings a couple of years ago a
side was taken I was a side that you
know many Americans are greeted with but
you can't do that right and the problem
is now it's not a matter of okay I think
the age to buy guns should be raised to
21 and no I think it shouldn't and
here's why
it's always you know what you're a bad
person you want children to die as a
result and and you know we saw it on the
conservative side as well on the liberal
side as far as people saying that these
children are actors actually being
coached please I mean I had a friend
that had a daughter in that school
hiding in a closet and the emotion is
real and I would never doubt these kids
in terms of their sentiment around this
they're not being coached Tucker yeah
because we're not liberals we support
the right of everybody even those we
disagree with to say what exactly what
they think we believe in a free speech
and we mean it Joe thank you so much
great to see it give you good to see you